bonsoir
c'est une question qui revient de façon
assez cyclique pourquoi est-ce que c'est
si important de changer ce nom Moncton
écoutez je pense que ça s'inscrit dans
une mouvance canadienne où on a beaucoup
moins de tolérance devant des décisions
qui ont été prises au cours des ans dans
le cas de Mountain il faut se rappeler
qu'en 1960 la création de l'université a
été un peu comme un cheval de Troie qui
est entré dans la ville de monkken
en laissant sous-entendre que
l'université pourrait devenir bilingue
un moment donné ou à un autre et c'est
dans ces circonstances là que
l'université a porté le nom de la ville
la ville qui elle avait reçu son nom
d'un officier britannique qui entre
1950 et juste copine d'Abraham à
exactement exercer sa profession
toujours dans l'optique de la conquête
du déplacement des populations
françaises donc il y a pas grand chose
c'est que le monsieur mankin puisse
obtenir ici beaucoup de faveurs de
quiconque et vous parlez de ce cheval de
Troie donc c'était déjà difficile de
créer cet université dans les années 60
et pourquoi avoir accepté ce nom à ce
moment-là parce que vous pouviez pas
l'empêcher bien écoute d'abord
impossible d'utiliser le mot académie le
nom universitaire puisque
idiots avait déjà subtilisé le nom
longtemps à l'avance deuxièmement on
avait des doutes chez les anglophones de
monken que c'était la bonne chose à
faire et troisièmement le Premier
ministre Louis Robuchon dans l'entourage
était surtout un établissement de
francophone du Sud-Est devait aussi
convaincre les gens du Nord les
francophones du Nord que c'était la
bonne chose à faire donc le nom n'était
pas probablement
important dans le contexte où on a créé
cette université
et qu'est-ce que ça représente ce
changement non pourquoi pourquoi c'est
si important au fond pour vous bien moi
je pense que après une soixantaine
d'années l'université a produit des
presque 100 milliers de gradués je pense
et à partir de ce moment-là la
communauté et pour la première fois en
position de prendre une décision et la
consolider ses assises dans le sud-est
une ville de 31
000 habitants francophones tout près de
Montaigne la ville de Montaigne est
maintenant bilingue tout ceci mis
ensemble fait que la communauté a le
droit de choisir et moi je pense qu'elle
va prendre la bonne décision évidemment
tout ça ça se produit dans un contexte
où vous le savez vous êtes historien en
déboulonne des statuts l'Université
Ryerson à Toronto a changé non vous
pensez que c'est un contexte qui peut
vous aider
moi je dirais que les carottes sont
cuites il est maintenant impossible pour
l'université de ne pas changer de nom
nous n'avons pas vu une seule personne
dans les derniers jours qui s'objectait
à cette démarche nous avons vu 800
personnes dans la grande majorité sont
des Ligueux où l'on était un moment ou
un autre moi je peux vous dire ceci
l'Université de Moncton aura un nouveau
nom bientôt ce sera quoi une libération
pour vous
écoutez moi dans mon cas je n'ai
peut-être pas vous savez la foi de
Monsieur Nadeau mais je pense que cette
lutte là était la bonne et ce sera selon
moi une affirmation
identitaire très important bon ça prend
évidemment un changement dans la loi
parce qu'il y a une loi de l'Université
de Moncton est-ce que vous pensez que ce
gouvernement en ce moment va vous
entendre
absolument il y a pas un gouvernement
qui pourra faire face à la fronde s'il y
en a une mais je vous dis que la teneur
des propos présentement et la lettre
qu'a reçu le recteur de l'université
pour faire en sorte que dans quelques
semaines la décision va se prendre et je
ne pense pas qu'un gouvernement puisse
se renverser cette volonté du peuple
alors on espère que vous serez entendu
monsieur Théréau merci beaucoup
merci